foreign
I just I don't see the light at the end
of the tunnel I work full time my
husband works full time we have two
little kids I think it's definitely
becoming obvious like my husband he's
not stupid he knows something's wrong he
asks I sugarcoat it and we kind of move
on with the week what you're doing is
being dishonest with him
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloney show
of all the trillions of podcasts
the architecture podcasts
how to make your grass really green
podcast you chose the greatest marriage
and parenting mental health podcast ever
in the history of podcasts
um and I've been told I can uh what's
the thing I think it's Mel Robin like
I'm I'm trying to speak it into
existence so I'm just going to say it
over and over what do you call it
visioneering what do you call that thing
when you imagine it it's like a it's
like a a an imaginary board what's not
the imaginary board what's the board
called the dream board or whatever a
vision board vision board what's the
thing when you imagine it like if I just
think about it it'll come
that's it manifesting hey John yes ma'am
please put a lid on that coffee cup
you're making me super nervous why
I spilled my
I'm gonna put a lid on this I'm gonna
put a lid on it
and put a lid on the coffee
I
yes ma'am
yes ma'am are you fling and I think I'm
the picture of stability but such it is
both psychologically and physically hey
if you want to be on the greatest show
ever the one that we are manifesting
right
um give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask by the way I did get just before the
show I got the the review the
metrics
have you seen this
yeah it's pretty incredible I don't know
I said so many people are watching
listening to the show I can't have my
head around it anymore
um
yeah it's amazing I I it's officially
not my mom anymore just she can't even
refresh that that quickly
um so I'm glad that you're with us make
sure that you leave reviews and tell
your friends and call your parents and
all that kind of stuff all right let's
go to Lauren in Denver Colorado what's
up Lauren
hey John thank you for taking my call of
course thanks for getting up super early
on the western side of America
no worries
I don't see the light at the end of the
tunnel I work full time my husband works
full time we have two little kids and it
just feels like every week some new
negative thing pops up into our life
that we have to deal with and uh I think
it's definitely becoming obvious like my
husband he's not stupid he knows
something's wrong he asks I sugarcoat it
and we kind of move on with the week and
uh we were gifted an opportunity coming
up where we get to have dinner and
somebody else is watching our kids for
us and he thought this would be a great
time for us to have a conversation of
like what do you want what do I want
what do we want for the future for our
family and I am just like terrified that
he's going to bring it up that I seem
anxious and stressed and he wants to
know what's wrong and I don't know how
to communicate that to him I was hoping
to get your advice on that
yes you just described millions and
millions of people and so thank you for
having the courage to call
um this conversation I think can help a
lot of people so thank you so much
um
so let's take the reality of stress okay
how old are your kids
uh three and one three and one so the
call you feeling stressed to the three
and a one-year-old a hundred percent
hear me say completely normal Okay and
like your whole world's exploded
somebody threw a grenade in the middle
of your house and you have a three and a
one year old and there's insane
Financial pressures right now right
yes and you live in a really expensive
part of the country right
yes and you and your husband how long
have you been married
uh almost four years okay and how long
did y'all date before that
for three years I think two or three
years okay so you got pregnant pretty
quick after you got married is that
right yes okay so let's go back to the
first few months when it was we can just
do whatever we want whenever we want
or maybe there's this moment where
you've never been able to just do
whatever you want whenever you want
because you got married and then you got
pregnant and then it's now the trains
left the station if you will all I have
to say is this the stresses you are
feeling are very very real who are we is
this what our marriage is gonna look
like
um we have sex annually now instead of
daily right like all these things shift
and change
and are you gonna go to work all the
time are you gonna get frustrated you're
gonna try to fix all those things are
real okay so I want to say all the
stress is real
when it comes to the anxiety describe
that for me tell me about it
so um
the brain society around that is like we
we're married we have joint income a
joint checking all that but the bulk of
that income comes from my paycheck and
so my husband like if he lost his job it
would suck but we we would survive our
bills would get paid on time if I lost
my job that would not be the case
um so that part stresses me out and then
makes me anxious at like something could
happen because
um I have a very flexible job I have a
work from home job great employer my
husband does not have that so if
something happens with the kids like
with school starting up we just found
out they won't get a bus they won't get
before school care there's no
after-school care because of low
Staffing so I have to rearrange my
schedule at work and then that makes me
anxious that like I'm not a good
employee and like what if I lost my job
but I have to do all these things for
the kids because all these services that
we were planning on relying on just got
taken away
so you sound like a single mom with
three kids
fathers don't exist they just you know
he took time off he took a day off when
my son had surgery and he caught so much
Flack from it I saw the text he was
getting from his boss and it was it's
horrible like he needs to quit that job
okay it won't cost Jill any money he
needs to quit that job
and he said go be around a culture of
Tradesmen that will love and honor him
as a dad and as a husband and as an
employee and they do exist because I
know them personally
um you want to see a room full of teary
big bellied
um sweaty men
like get a group of Tradesmen in a room
when one of their buddies is having a
baby
it's one of the coolest things you'll
ever see or when somebody when they all
show up to the hospital to be with
somebody whose wife just passed away
um I've been in there too it's it's
unbelievable the amount of emotion and
love in there so your husband's it's not
the industry he's got a crappy situation
his boss sucks boss is terrible okay
um
hey he's not on the phone with me so I'm
just going to talk to you okay
what you're doing is being dishonest
with him
you're not telling him the truth and
what happens is when you you don't tell
them what you need what you're scared
about what you're anxious about and you
swallow all that and sit on it
he like you mentioned he knows y'all are
disconnected
and the problem is he thinks it's him
and a part of it might be him the fact
that he doesn't make enough money and
that y'all have a lifestyle that's not
sustainable if one of you lost your job
all that kind of stuff or that you are
having to do all the work you just
mentioned plus laundry plus keep the
kids bathed and do bedtime all that
but if you don't test it down and say
here's what I need
I need us to reconnect I need us to
figure out what intimacy looks like with
a three and a one year old I need you to
help me with bedtime I need you like if
I need here's my list of needs
um if you don't do that
um
I think it's it's dishonest it's just
not fair
yeah right what is it about your needs
that you feel like cannot be told cannot
be said is he gonna get mad is he going
to hit you is he going to scream what
why won't you tell him
so he doesn't really get mad he feels
guilty he has an immense amount of guilt
going into the trades his family was
very anti-trades um they looked down on
him for it and I was like the first
person to come in his life that was the
opposite I said I love that you're in
the trades like that's huge for our kids
to know that they don't have to go to a
four-year traditional College like I
love that and I feel like if I try to
explain to him the stress that I have
it's going to go back to him feeling
guilty that he'd never finish college
him feeling guilty that he's not
bringing home enough money or that he
chose look at the world you've just
created okay I'm the first person to
tell them that trades are okay and
they're Noble and they're great and by
the way they are
and
he's not making enough money for me to
feel safe at home and he's so busy that
he can't help with anything at home so
you want your kids to like see their dad
and be like you can do anything you
don't even have to go to four-year
college and by the way this is going to
create a life that makes it really hard
for parents to be connected and safe
yeah that makes sense see what I'm
saying so you're you're you're cheering
a football play that's not working
now this isn't me bagging on the trades
this is that your husband had it has
picked a company in a group that aren't
paying what he's worth because the
numbers we're getting here on trades are
through the roof what does he do what
kind of trade does he actually do
uh so he's a car he was a carpenter now
he's a site supervisor okay
um he needs to go get another job
like ASAP
and a job that doubles or triples or
quadruples his income
and here's a hard hard thing for you as
a wife to hear you cannot solve and fix
his guilt
you can only tell them the truth and it
with with dignity and respect
okay okay you trying to protect him
makes you his mother not his wife
yeah that makes sense are you trying to
and who and I say this with all due
respect but who wants to sleep with
their son who wants to who wants to
sleep with their mom right so it creates
a really weird intimacy dynamic
when he's looking for you to feel less
guilty
and you have to Pat him on the head and
say it'll be okay
and then he goes to bed after three
beers on the couch and I'm just making
this up hey who knows he may be a great
guy
um but then you have to go figure out
how to do laundry but see what I'm
saying like it's just none of this is
true and then let me let me be real
honest with you this ends badly
in one of two ways one of you is going
to over time seek connection elsewhere
whether it's from alcohol whether it's
from a second drink whether it's from
somebody at work that's really funny and
thinks you're funny too
that or what I'm coming to believe is
worse
is you'll both find yourselves on
opposite recliners staring at a big flat
screen TV
and that will be your 40s and 50s and
60s and then you won't have the energy
to roll around with your grandkids and
that'll just we'll just call it a life
after that
yeah that kind of feels like where it's
headed yeah right right so
let's stop that train Fort leaves the
station you got a three and a one year
old this is the and your husband's
actually doing the super right thing
which is all right we got a
three-year-old a one-year-old we've been
married for like two months without
being without being pregnant with kids
let's let's get ahead of this and let's
create the marriage that we want let's
say all the things how it's going to
look let's go make that happen
and I think it's
less about hey honey you need to go make
more money
this is you saying I see a gr is he a
hard worker
yes is he good at what he does he's a
good Carpenter yes
um good supervisor takes care of his men
he loves his guys
yes definitely okay
this conversation looks like this
um
honey I see how good you are with your
the men and women that report to you I
see how good you are coming under budget
you're a credible teacher you're a great
uh
whatever uh Carpenter
and where you work I'm sick of watching
a group of people not value you I'm
asking you as your wife to go find
somebody who will value you both
financially and your expertise and your
most important calling which is being a
dad and a husband
that's different than you got to go make
more money because one of those is like
there goes the shame conversation the
other is hey we picked this I'm all in
um they don't value you
and I'm tired of seeing the man that I
love not be valued
three months old and he he has a history
of job hopping prior to that he was not
great with jobs uh he would get you know
mad at a boss and walk off the job site
and when my daughter was three months
old he did that and it turned into a
huge fight and I accused him a job
hopping and he got a new job and hasn't
done that since then so I think it's
going to be a New Perspective him
hearing me tell him to go get a new job
but I think he'll be happy he might but
also he acted like a child that was a
temper tantrum
yeah right that was a third grader
temper tantrum again going back to you
you're a single mom with three kids
and it may even be that he got into the
trades not because he's got this calling
to be a carpenter or a plumber which is
a noble incredible profession but ain't
gonna tell me I'm going to college I'm
gonna go do this you see what I'm saying
yeah and so
um people in his life might have told
him no dude you were put on Earth to be
a surgeon are you put on Earth to be a
computer programmer and yet you ran into
a couple of professors that were mean or
you didn't get straight A's you had to
work really hard or whatever the thing
is and he's like I'm out of here and
quit that just like you quit the job
site number one and job site number two
yeah and so there is no shame none zero
of saying okay cool I didn't go finish
college I went and ran the trades and
I'm now at the top of what I can do in
my area I make 33 000 which I don't buy
by the way but let's just say that's
that's the truth
there's no shame in going back to school
there's no shame in saying okay what do
we want to do now let's just let's pivot
let's do something different right you
see what I'm saying and giving him the
freedom to do that but he has to have a
job
right that makes sense okay
um you cannot allow his
well I just feel guilty and set
that's not an excuse you got to tell
them hey I can't carry this whole house
and I'd rather be your wife than your
mom
is that cool
yeah I think that sounds good are you
gonna actually do this are you gonna
chicken out
I think honestly because
I think you're gonna have to say none of
this stuff
I think you're gonna say no it's good I
just I just
um I need to get in the gym more and
he'll be like okay and then that'll be
it
so normally that probably is how the
conversation would go but because we got
this opportunity to go to a restaurant
and you know there's obviously drinks
involved I'm sure I'd be more likely to
actually tell them the truth
oh nothing sounds like romance like I'll
tell them the truth when I've been
drinking
way to go Lauren that's love love love
um
it's super not but you know what I mean
so do me a favor write this stuff down
before you go because you're going to
get nervous and you're gonna forget and
he's gonna make faces or you're going to
see that that Grimace of of guilt or I'm
so sorry I should have been I know I did
and you tell them hey let me finish this
and I want you to write it all down okay
and if he's struggling in that
conversation or he hears some things
that are hard for him to hear
um and he wants to act like a child
about it and throw a temper tantrum
about it
um then I want you to have him call me
okay I don't think he's going too I'm
hoping he hears you
I'm hoping you can sit down at the table
and say dude I'm super excited to build
a life that we want that's going to be
different than any of our parents had
we're gonna make this up and not as we
go but we're gonna plan and we're gonna
go get there and uh we're gonna go make
this thing happen and it's gonna start
with you going back to school or you get
a new job where they honor you I'm gonna
stop having to do all this work because
you're going to be a co-helper in this
home and we're gonna get our sexy back
yeah and we're gonna do we're just gonna
make it happen all right hey I'm gonna
send you a copy I'm sending you two
copies of redefining anxiety in my book
on anxiety and you and your husband can
read through it together and it's got
the three points there about connection
about being scared and about autonomy
like we're in control of what comes next
and y'all could talk through those
things as you build this new life I'm
excited to find out how this
conversation goes uh get back in touch
with me let me know how it goes I can't
wait to hear about it we'll be right
back
hey what's up deloney here I've got a
word from our sponsor better help I'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way burnout is when
your body has enough and it says I'm out
I'm done it's that deep feeling of
exhaustion after a long period of being
overworked and over stressed and just
fried and most of us associate burnout
with work but burnout can happen at any
area of our lives and it can cause a
lack of motivation irritability fatigue
or randomly crying at some random song
on the radio or when somebody looks at
you the wrong way and that's why I love
my friends that better help better help
online therapy exists to give you the
chance to invest in your healing better
help is customize online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with you and your therapist you
never have to even see anyone on camera
if you don't want to it's more
affordable than in-person therapy plus
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours and today our list owners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com deloney that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go to Danielle oh and my
arch nemesis Town College Station what's
up Danielle
hey how's it going good are you an Aggie
I am not ah Danielle actually I love
Aggies they're great too I just went to
I was in Lubbock and so you know how
that goes uh yeah how we doing
I'm doing okay I'm doing okay how are
you I'm fantastic rocking on to the
Breaking Dawn what's up Daniel how can I
help
all right so
um in April of last year I uh attempted
uh suicide and I was put in a mental
facility for a couple of weeks or so
um so the main thing I'm struggling with
is I feel like I'm stuck in between two
different people like who I was and who
I'm trying to become
[Music]
um I've got two best friends one
particular that I've had for over 25
years
and ever since this happened there's I
just feel like no connection you know
it's like um
the friendship and everything is stuck
in the past and there's no way to move
forward we barely text you know a couple
of sentences here and there
um one of them is actually the one that
found me that day
um so it's
I just I don't know what to do to move
forward and and I also feel like I'm
pushing them away as well
um I just feel really really stuck and I
don't I don't feel any connection
whatsoever yeah well I'm glad that
you're let me say this I'm glad that
you're with us
thank you are you glad that you're with
us
yeah yeah yeah most days yeah okay good
um I'll take most days today
um but I'm glad that you're with us on
all days
College Station needs you that's what
I'm saying
um
so you as you were describing this just
at the very beginning like I feel like
I'm stuck between who I was and who I
want to become the first like that's so
that's that's poetically stated like
that's such a beautiful way to state
that
and
right when you said that the first thing
I thought was this is going to be about
the friends of the past and loneliness
in your future right because often who
we are is our culture it's the people we
spend time with it's the things we do
the things we think are funny and now
we're transitioning to here's who I want
to become and then our friends don't
always go with us and that's hard right
um
so I want to give you some peace and let
you know that you're in an exercise
program and you were right in the middle
of it where you feel good about going to
the gym
and these pictures that you put on your
fridge on your manifest board or
whatever you don't quite have giant
muscles like that but you're on the way
and right now you're just tired and it
doesn't feel good anymore it's just
boring to get up at 5am and go to the
gym every day that's where you are in
terms of this new light right so
where you are is absolutely normal I
know that's both like oh good and that's
not good right I don't know what it
could be normal
um
very very common
with friends who are walking alongside
somebody who
um
tries to die by Suicide
there's trauma involved there especially
like you said your friend found you what
did she find how'd you try to take your
life
um alcohol and drugs okay so did she
find you passed out somewhere
yeah basically okay
um I can tell you I've been in that
situation where I walk in a place where
someone has taken a whole um a whole lot
of pills and drank a lot to where
they're unresponsive and I do this I did
it for a living right go in people's
houses and it's scary a couple of those
are lodged into my head forever and I
wasn't best friends with them okay so I
tell you that to tell you this
there's just an awkward like I she saw
some stuff
that scared her and a lot of us don't
have tools on how to enter back into
relationships there
she choose the type that doesn't deal
well with this kind of thing at all just
to begin with yeah so
here's the question you have to ask
yourself you've got 25 years with this
friend is this a friend that you value
that relationship like you would love to
see it
um not come back to the way it was
because it'll never be the way it was
but it could be so much better right so
is this a relationship that you have
interest in growing into the future or
or are you just coming to terms with
it's kind of played itself out
no I mean she's she's like a after my
always been she she watched my daughter
while I was in the hospital oh wow my
husband was you know just so taken back
and could barely keep himself together
she helped out with that okay
um
you may have already done this but
here's what I would do if I was you this
is the best advice I can give you just
what I would do I would take my friend
out
and go get coffee or go get breakfast or
I might save my money and go get a nice
meal
and at the meal say hey
um
I was ready to not be here anymore I was
ready for the pain to stop and you saved
my life
and I also
because of me you saw some really hard
things and I'm sorry and I'm so glad you
were there to help me
and
um I love you and I value our friendship
um and I've noticed that we're just
disconnected I want to invite you back
in to my heart into my life I will never
do that again but I also know there's
going to be some friendship healing
there
and um I'd love I'd love to do that with
you
all right here here's what this does
number one it lets her know that you
know
that
um she saw some hard things
she she's you scared her right yeah
um and she saw some hard things and she
had to see some things to do some things
that she never dreamed she was gonna
have to do so by you calling that out it
kind of clears the air right like I know
that you know that I know that you know
right and then the second is telling her
I love you and I know that now things
are awkward so I'm just addressing the
elephant in the room there's a huge
elephant in this room yeah the third
thing is
I'm willing to build something beautiful
with you moving forward if you are
here's the scary part of that last one
she may say no
and I I had a um I had a uh like a a
one-year celebration type thing just for
staying sober and everything
um and she was the only one that didn't
show up yeah
I would not take that personal
okay
okay that wasn't about you that was
about her
foreign
recovery from addiction
is you can control what you can control
which are your thoughts and your actions
and that's it
and I'm not going I'm going to choose to
not take personal what other people do
to keep themselves well and to keep
themselves safe
and so for whatever reason she felt like
um I won't be okay if I go so I'm going
to stay here
all right and man what a great friend
that you know loves herself is
self-aware enough to not come blow your
party up in your celebration up with her
her the things she's struggling with
right that's true pretty cool
and you could take that as she loved you
so much that she wasn't going to do that
for your party
but it wouldn't surprise me if she still
has pictures of you in her head crashed
out on the floor and not responsive and
her screaming and her trying to get you
to wake up like in the flashing lights
all those things I've been there and
I've seen it and it's a lot
and so it's just honoring that oh yeah
she's been through she's been through
hell and thank God she did because she
saved my life and I'm gonna I'm just
gonna put that out on the table
I'm gonna tell my friend I miss her
and she might look at you and say I just
can't I can't get back to where we were
I feel like you violated our friendship
you didn't call me like whatever and
she gets to do that and my guess is
she'll heal over time
but I think you having that conversation
is going to be really important
okay
I think it'll be a gift to you it'll be
a gift to her because at least you won't
be a limbo anymore
right you'll know right yeah that's what
it feels like but I've talked to her a
little bit
um about it
um she just she doesn't she can't really
talk about it she just says you know it
was hard and and then that's it like she
just has done with the conversation
which I totally get
um but I just feel like
it's just always there like yes it's
just always hovering and it's and you
know I don't drink anymore obviously
um and you know she does and I just feel
like are we ever gonna reach that point
where we can be friends and not have
this past but only see like the future
and not you know feel
like man if we were drinking this would
be so much easier exactly right hey
let's let's call it out it would be so
hard if y'all both had a few drinks
y'all could get to the core issue real
fast right yeah yeah and everybody knows
that
that's the importance of going back to
what I told earlier that's the
importance of you setting this on the
table first
right and when you not you but when we
enter into hard conversations and we ask
the other person like
you know won't you tell me you're not
talking to me we're making it all on
them
so there's something about you sitting
down and saying hey you saw me sprawled
out on the floor
and I can only imagine that those
ambulance lights are burned into your
brain and you picking me up and me just
being limp there and you wondering if I
was dead and you trying to find the
phone like
put a couple of details out there
yeah and let her know that you know that
what she experienced was really hard
and let her know that you love her
right and it may just be time to take a
break and you'll grieve that and you'll
mourn it but also you'll also be
grateful for the 25 years y'all had
together
right and by the way let's take the
let's take the suicide attempt off the
table
very very common when somebody goes
through
um when they someone goes through
recovery and gets sober that they have
they lose their friends
because
there's a lot of a lot of us that can't
not a lot of us but a lot of folks who
cannot manage social situations without
alcohol
yeah and they don't know what to do
you're sobriety is a challenge to the
way they have to get through their day
they feel like
yeah but do you see how that's their
issue not yours
dead than fat right I can say it all
like yeah yeah it's your problem but it
hurts
um tell me about this little baby girl
yours
you know she's the light of my life of
course it's beautiful
oh yeah definitely
and my husband
um the you know those two are the reason
I get up every day for sure
okay I'm gonna tell you a few things I
don't want you to hear me really really
carefully okay
um
you are the reason they get up every day
yeah
and that means you're worth being loved
and you are loved by two of your
favorite people in the world the one
person that's struggling to love
Danielle right now is Danielle
yeah okay
so here's what I want you to do
I want you to
get a brick
and I want you to put a piece of masking
tape or duct tape on it
and write the first six years
just write the first six years on it I
want you to carry it around for a little
bit
because here's my guess tell me if I'm
wrong
that now that you're sober you're you
celebrated a year recovery
uh April was a year I mean I had
honestly I counted but I don't count it
because I'm on medication too oh sister
count it count it I'm counting it you
don't have counter I'm counted
medication doesn't count goofball
um yes count it good grief
um count it
um but I want you to carry a brick that
says the first six years because my
guess is
now that you're sober you look back at
the first six seven years of that little
girl's life and you beat yourself up
mercilessly
stop yep stop
okay
I want you to carry that brick around
for about 20 or 30 minutes and then I
want you to go set it somewhere in the
corner of your backyard and never pick
it up again
okay
because the greatest gift you can give
your there's not there's a period at the
end of that sentence it happened
with that little nine-year-old ray of
light is looking for is Mama and she
sees her every morning
right
right yeah
and she's saying hey Mom let's go let's
go forward let's go this way
same with husband too is that right
yeah yeah for sure you like that guy too
yeah does he have a mustache
okay that's fantastic I support that I
don't know about these mustache guys
that are coming back yeah yeah I know
yeah
um
it's gonna be a season getting a new
community okay and it's gonna be super
important for you to continue to remind
yourself
that other people's decision to not join
you in an event and a thing that's their
choice not yours
that's their challenge is not yours okay
they get to make that choice and it's
not a reflection of you it's a
reflection of them
and that's okay
okay
like of all the brave people I talk to
on a regular basis on this show you're
at the very tip top
so what you've done is real real hard
yeah
and you've got strength that very very
few people have and I want you to I want
you to know it's an honor to talk to you
okay
um
with all of your old friends you know
there's some that I need to be done with
I don't need to be in a relationship
with them and when you get lonely it's
easy to call them back right so we're
staying away from them
are you still seeing a counselor
I guess you're still you're still taking
meds you're still are you still seeing
somebody
I'm still on meds um I see I have a
counselor but I haven't seen her
seniors February or January okay
um
yeah let's reach back out here's what
you're all going to practice you're
gonna practice
um making new friends because that's
hard and it's miserable and it's
terrible yeah I don't want to do that I
know but you have to
you have to
and yeah I think you do want to
you don't want to get rejected you want
to go through all the awkward and weird
and one day you're gonna have to explain
yeah I I am in rehabit or to wear it you
know I do I have to do that though I
think
that's what I'm afraid of with meeting
people like
do I need to tell them my past
I feel like I do but I mean not like hi
my name is Danielle I used to be an
adult no no yeah but I don't know I just
feel like this is such a huge part of me
like
I want it to go away but at the same
time I don't because it reminds me you
know and I don't know if that's the
right way to feel about it or not
you're wearing this as an identity
you're wearing a shame I feel like it
identifies who I am it doesn't
what identifies you as Who You Are
is the joy you bring into a room
and the hugs you give that little
nine-year-old girl
and that scruffy bearded husband of
yours
when he digs his face into your neck
and you go into whatever Church there in
College Station and just putting your
head down and holding your hands up and
saying this is bigger than me
going for a walk there in Texas when
it's a billion degrees and saying oh
yeah
um right you see I'm saying like that's
your identity
you are not the worst thing you've ever
done
you're not ever stop feeling like it is
hard but when you stop calling yourself
that
thank you
no it's not gonna magically just quit
you've got to stop talking to yourself
that way and then you've got to live
into a new identity
right yeah so that makes sense here's
how it works it's not
um I'm a former addict who almost died
by suicide because I needed the pain to
stop I needed to stop I needed to stop
that's you saying this is who I am
or
dude I'm a mama who loves her kids and
loves her husband and the best way I can
love my kid and my husband is by loving
myself
and making sure I take care I'm a pro
I'm a person who takes care of my body
I'm a person who takes care of my head
my mind
I'm a person who has lots and lots of
friends
the person who's got this clock it's
like you're looking up and you see dark
clouds
yeah constantly but you don't realize
that when everyone's looking at you they
just see a tiny little Cloud over your
tiny little head and it's raining just
on you
because the sun's out everywhere well
yeah
and when you choose a new identity which
is now there's Sunshine out here
hard stuff man hard stuff and you're
chilling out your brain chemistry and
working through all those things I'm
proud of you for still taking your meds
keep doing that
um oh yeah I wouldn't make it without
them hey don't apologize for that
like that's not that's not a step down
you're not a lesser person you're not
some kind of somehow weaker because of
that they'll tell you that crap on
Instagram but you're not there's a
billion people who have heart
transplants that have to take
anti-rejection medication for the rest
of their lives it keeps them alive
and it gives their kids a dad
yeah that's true and it gives their moms
right I mean gives them somebody to
cheer for them at graduation because
mom's still around
take your meds with a smile on your face
you live in a sliver of History
where they've created some paths forward
for us that are pretty amazing
right
right it's awesome
congratulations and
my guess is over time
depending on what what what
um psychiatric challenges you're
wrestling with
a new community a community of people
who love you that you can be fully
yourself
and lean into your new identities
dealing with some of the traumas from
your past and creating new memories for
you and your husband and your kid and
new ways of being
that your body will begin to heal much
quicker than you think
okay
all right so stay on the line I'm gonna
send you a copy of on your past change
your future it's I want you to read it
and I want you to let me know what you
think about it okay in fact I'm gonna
send you two I want you to read them
with your husband oh you got it I have
it and I haven't I haven't been able to
finish it I I read about halfway through
and I had to stop there you go you know
the back half is right is what do you do
next
yeah
it's time yeah yeah
you're right is it cool
will your husband read it with you
oh yeah if I ask you we will okay let's
do this I'm gonna send you another one
and I want you all to read it together
and you can start over at the beginning
and just make a breakfast date once uh
once a week or once a month you're going
to talk about the latest chapter you
just read
okay some of it y'all will disagree with
that's not true that's fine
but when you get to the
um
hey this happened
this happened to me and here's the other
story
um struggling with addiction you were
you went through some stuff when you
were younger didn't you
oh yeah yeah
I've I've completely stopped
thinking and this has been several years
um I completely stopped thinking when
someone tells me that they're in
recovery is like I can't believe you did
drugs you know you my thoughts are wow
what happened that was
can only imagine what happened that was
so ugly and so hard that this was the
best you I mean this was the best path
forward to you just so you could get up
every day right yeah
so those things happened
and we're gonna feel them and we're
gonna own them they happen they happen
they happen
and then we're gonna ask ourselves the
scariest question any of us can ever ask
which is what do we do now
right right
and the cool part is that what he do now
is pretty simple and the not cool part
is man it's really hard it's really hard
right yeah yeah right
I'm so so proud of you
thank you and I don't lie on the show I
lie a lot in my personal life just
kidding I don't really
um but I don't lie on the show I'm proud
of you what you're doing is really
strong and my hope is next time we talk
you're gonna say I'm the reason I get up
every morning
because I love me and I love being on
the wake-up roll and I love the sunshine
outside and it doesn't ever rain in
Texas but one day it might and you can
love the rain it happens and you're
gonna love your husband and you're gonna
love that beautiful daughter of yours
too
yeah right yep right yeah
you're in it for the Long Haul
I am yeah definitely you're never gonna
hurt yourself again
no
say it with confidence
[Music]
if you're in it for the long haul I am
too
I'll walk with you any way you need over
the next however long until they cancel
the show okay
proud of you holler at me if I can never
help with anything or walk through
anything have your husband give me a
shout
um if he ever wants to okay proud of you
proud of the
your husband sounds great just amazing
it's amazing glad that you're with us
you my sister Danielle from College
Station Texas are not a burden
all of our lives are better because
you're still here we'll be right back
hey good folks Dr John deloney here all
right we have to talk about sleep when
life gets busy it's the first thing we
neglect we stay up later we binge
another series and we think we can do
everything I know because I've been
guilty of it but you and me and all of
us we have to change we need sleep sleep
is at the core of every mental physical
and relational thing we do and I found a
good night's sleep starts with a great
mattress and that's why I love dream
Cloud mattresses and right now dream
cloud is running their biggest offer
ever just for our listeners you can get
599 dollars in accessories plus an
additional 250 cash discount that's a
total of
849 dollars in accessories and savings
that's pillows a mattress protector and
luxury sheets it's time to prioritize
getting the rest your body and your mind
need because your mental health matters
so go to dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dream cloudsleep.com and enter promo
code deloni to get your new mattress
today and enjoy 849 dollars in savings
and accessories
all right we're back
back I've been getting this question a
lot on the internets on social media and
a couple of Studies have come out
recently so I thought it's an important
thing to address
um the question here's an email from
Sarah and it just says can trauma cause
weight gain
and how do you work through enough
trauma that your body responds well to
things you're trying to do to lose
weight
so let me
take a stab at answering this
um
I want to think of trauma as your body
telling itself a story in the present
based on things that happened to it in
the past okay so what does that mean
that means you were taking a left turn
coming over a hill and somebody T-boned
you in their truck because they're
flying down the road weren't paying
attention and somebody in your family
passed away and you were in the hospital
for a while
now 20 years later every time you stop
in an intersection to take a left turn
you feel yourself getting antsy you grab
the wheel a little bit tighter your
heart starts beating faster
that's your body remembering in the
present something that happened to you a
long time ago and since our brains are
prediction machines and threat scanning
machines and I hate calling them
machines but just go with me here since
that's what your brain's doing all the
time it remembers it put a pin in that
hey when you're about to make a left
turn that's when somebody gets hurt so
when you're about to make a left turn
all of a sudden man your heart starts
beating fast you feel a little bit alive
your body fills up with stress and
cortisol and adrenaline that's what it's
doing
or more insidiously
you had a feeling that I don't want to
be around that Uncle I don't want to be
around that guy at my church I don't
want to be around that guy that teacher
that guy makes me feel uncomfortable and
their parents said oh that's just Uncle
so and so go give him a hug go sit on
his lap or that's just Sunday school
teacher bill go he's fine oh gosh my kid
just she's just shy
and that person sexually abuses you
and whether it's a particular smell or a
particular lighting Arrangement or
particular
way of talking or way of standing
whatever it is
your brain now is on the lookout
because certain relationships will get
you hurt so let's have none of them okay
that's trauma right that's that's a
thing that happened that now our body is
trying to take care of us into the
future
all right so whenever our body
hits the trauma button hey look out we
got to protect ourselves right it goes
into fight or flight or goes into freeze
and it floods your body with with
response chemicals to fight a bear or to
run from a bear or to hide from a bear
right
not to have to go to work every day
where they make fun of you and they are
merciless against you
um or not to have to be in a
relationship where someone's taking
advantage of you again because it
happened before and happened before that
happened before that and that's the
relationship that part of your body
knows and also the other part of your
body knows this relationship isn't safe
right so we play these things out over
and over and over again
a couple of things at play here
there are some studies that have come
out that suggest that say that women who
are obese are more likely to have uh a
significant number of them let me say it
carefully have experienced sexual trauma
and some people pontificate they
um suggest that it might be somebody
unconsciously trying to make themselves
less presentable
so that people won't find them desirable
people won't try to sexually abuse them
other Scholars suggest that it's a way
of hiding within yourself kind of like
when a kid puts their hair down in front
of their fake my daughter does this
she'll like hide behind her own hair
um in the living room right or I used to
wear big giant baggy clothes because I
was a skinny kid and I wanted to look
bigger and tougher it's a way to hide
inside of yourself okay
um
what I know is this I don't know the ins
and outs of the science I do know this
trauma
when that kicks up for the fight or
flight sometimes our bodies want to go
grab cheap calories
two because we're gonna be running and
fighting things and so we're going to
grab the nearest food and right now we
are having abundance of cheap calories
that we're going to grab and grab and
eat and eat and eat so that's number one
yes so it's not so much the trauma is
causing obesity
but it's trauma kicks off some behaviors
in our lives that then cause obesity
right see what I'm saying
um Paul Conti's work the the brilliant
um he wrote a great book called trauma
uh he's a psychiatrist I think he's in
New York or in California I'm pretty
sure New York
um great book but he's told numerous
stories as a psychiatrist that when he's
treating somebody he's treating somebody
he's treating somebody as a medical
doctor and as a as a psychiatrist
they deal with their trauma and boom
they lose 60 pounds they lose 30 pounds
their body releases that weight that
it's been using to protect itself or
maybe eating pattern shift or maybe
people can finally sleep and that less
that um uh the de-elevated uh the
de-escalated cortisol in the bloodstream
like whatever it happens to be right we
can go down the nerd thing we're gonna
do that
here's what I want you to know
when it comes to how do you work through
enough trauma that your body responds
well to things you're trying to do to
lose weight a couple of thoughts there
number one here's how you quote unquote
heal from trauma trauma healing is not
that you forget what happened you're not
ever going to forget what happened
it's that you can remember it in the
present and your body doesn't take off
on you
you remember the wreck when your husband
died
you remember when your granddad dropped
with a heart attack and you and your dad
tried to do CPR and he ended up dying
and you remember how hard your dad was
crying
and you still get sad
but you can go about your day
that's healing from trauma I can I can
think about it I can imagine it but I
don't re-experience it okay so when
someone asked me like how do I heal from
trauma I keep thinking about it of
course you're going to think about it
is your body taken off on you right is
your body trying to protect you still
then you haven't fully healed from it so
that's number one let's heal with the
trauma in a way that and I can talk
about it this happened and it's super
annoying and it still pisses me off
but I don't lose control of my body and
number two
ultimately losing weight for most folks
losing weight is dealing with the
psychology of it all and dealing with a
psychology so I can make different
behavioral choices
I can eat differently I can change my
food environment I can make different
choices and there's plenty of research
about when you get tired you make bad
diet choices when you get stressed you
make bad diet choices these studies
linking a trauma to obesity right so
it's about the environment because
ultimately it's about what I'm putting
in my mouth right what I'm eating or not
eating and so
anybody who's had trauma
go deal with that
if you're struggling with losing weight
as a and you think it's connected in
some way had that conversation with your
mental health professional also have
that conversation with your nutritionist
or the person that you're getting your
workout from when we were in California
recently and I think the interview will
be coming out with the Mind pump guys I
had some hard conversations about
my history with disordered eating and
struggles I have with body dysmorphia
and the bar always moving on me and all
this kind of stuff and they taught me
some really important things that I've
come home the last month and already
implemented right and that interview
will be dropping here in a few weeks I
think
um all I have to say is this
heal from your trauma
be highly intentional if you are
somebody who struggles with obesity meet
with your doctor meet with a mental
health professional and get on a plan
and then
feel less think less
follow the plan follow the plan follow
the plan
hope that helps Sarah thank you so so
much we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show hey
Kelly curveball um my son and I were at
a UCD shop the other day buying ucds
because it's the 1400s didn't put in my
CD player in my truck and
um guess what I found in there
the Metallica Black Album oh there we go
dude that record is so good start to
finish it's incredible
but shout out to Danielle from College
Station earlier in the show man one of
my favorite songs on that record is
personified addiction talking to the
person that it owns
in the song called sad but true and so
I'm going to wrap up the the song the
Today's Show with sad but true one of my
favorite songs off the Metallica Black
Album it goes like this hey I'm your
life and I'm the one who takes you there
I'm your life and I'm the one who cares
they they betray I'm your only true
friend now
I'm forever there in your dream make you
real in your eyes when you have to steal
in your pain when you can't feel it's
sad but true
you you're my mask you're my cover
you're my shelter you're the one who's
blamed do my work do my Dirty Work
scapegoat do my Deeds for you're the one
who's shamed
I'm your dream I'm your eyes I'm your
pain
[Music]
what a great picture of how addiction
gets inside of us and takes over
everything
leave it to James and Lars
just speak from the heart we'll see you
soon
[Music]